you've had sex and so has she so I why
was this such a sticking point then
think about what you're asking
you've been doing these tiles for a long
time tonight Luke came at you with a lot
of comments things like you know think
about your question and stuff like that
what was going through your mind when
Luke was challenging you on how you were
conducting the interview I got what he
was trying to do I think being a dad and
having a little age and wisdom and doing
this for 17 years help tonight because
yeah I needed patience to get through
this because it would have been easy to
fall for those jabs and to make this
contentious that's probably what he
wanted was there to be a contentious
battle between us and just kept going in
the direction I wanted to go which was
have this conversation with him I wanted
to kind of have this level of debate of
religion and belief and how you apply it
to your life and how he applied it to
Hannah and how he shamed her made her
feel shamed how he changed the direction
of her show do you think that you made
any headway with him tonight or was he
not getting any of it I don't think I in
my opinion I don't think he got any of
it I think he needs time I think in his
world life is black and white in the
real world there's a big gray area in
the middle I don't think he's found the
gray area of life and I would just say
to him find the gray area Luke it's
beautiful do you think that Hannah said
all that needed to be said tonight at
the tell-all
she said everything and I mean she cut
that guy off at the knees I was so proud
of her tonight I mean she owned it and
what I really love and I will say this
about empowerment whether it's men
whether it's women I love that her
empowerment comes from frailty and comes
from vulnerability and I think there is
this misconception right now that to be
powerful you have to be strong powerful
perfect always that's not where it comes
from and I love tonight that she owned
the fact that it was her insecurities
that drove her into this relationship
with Luke but she now has the you know
she's learned from that and she's come
back so I just love that that's what her
power her empowerment came from tonight
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]